Offensive messages.
Tucker Carlson sent showing contempt for Fox News.
Management and colleagues were a major factor in the company's decision to oust him Monday.
According to people familiar with the matter,
the move took Carlson off the air a shock to the host and his large audience
making the previous Friday show his last and we'll be back on Monday in the
meantime,
have the best weekend with the ones that you love and we'll see you then culturally,
it's a big deal because Tucker Carlson was one of the most well known
TV personalities and the highest rated primetime host.
Here's a look at the private messages that led to Carlson's surprise ouster and what's next
to the former host and the network ahead of Fox's defamation trial
against Dominion voting systems.
People familiar with the matter say Fox News lawyers presented Carlson with what they
thought was good news.
They told him the court would redact from a legal filing the time he called a senior
Fox News executive,
the C word,
but Carlson was impressed,
he told his colleagues he wanted the world to know what he said about the executive
internal messages.
Um Many of which were from Tucker Carlson to other colleagues
were made public in the discovery process and some of those ended up
being redacted.
But in them,
Mr Carlson made disparaging remarks about some of his colleagues and other
people at the network.
The court filings also revealed an exchange where Carlson called for the firing of a Fox
news reporter for fact checking.
Donald Trump's false claims about the 2020 election.
Please get her fired.
Carlson wrote,
it's measurably hurting the company.
In another message,
Carlson is shown complaining about the network's news coverage including its
decision to call Arizona for Joe Biden on election night.
According to one document he wrote,
we devote our to building an audience and they let Chris Wallace and Leland vitter
wreck it and included an obscenity in the messages.
Carlson also made disparaging comments about on air guests and former president Donald
Trump.
He wrote in a January 2021 text message that he was very
close to being able to ignore Trump most nights and that I hate him
passionately.
Although many portions of the Dominion court documents are there was concern
among Fox executives that if the redacted material were to become public,
it would lead to further embarrassment for the network and the parent company.
And on Monday,
the network said it would part ways with the popular host.
Tucker found out about 10 minutes before it was announced by the
company,
Fox News Media and Tucker Carlson have mutually agreed to part ways.
Carlson declined to comment on his departure within Fox.
People familiar with the matter said reservations had been mounting about risks.
Carlson presented for the network landing blue chip advertisers for his show was an
issue.
Fox struggled with getting advertisers at eight pm on Tucker's show partially
because of controversial remarks he made on a number of different topics.
His commentary had grown more extreme and expanded beyond a conservative
viewpoint on politics.
Female athletes are losing NCAA ships to men dressing up as
women in order to cheat their way to victory.
Democrats hate the police because they don't control the police.
Very simple.
So what is equity?
Well,
tonight,
finally,
we know what it is equity.
It turns out is racism.
Carlson trafficked in what critics and even some higher ups within Fox felt was thinly
veiled racism such as this recent show where he's talking about one of the Tennessee
lawmakers protesting for stricter gun control.
Justin Pearson wasn't white.
That's probably how we got into Boden in the first place,
but he did a fantastic impression of it.
What a nice young man as he considered the apprenticeship program at Citibank.
The former host is also a defendant in a separate lawsuit that was filed last month by Abby
Grossberg,
a former producer for Carlson.
I was hoping that it would be more professional and what he was portraying on air was
just a show.
And unfortunately,
that wasn't the case.
The Abby Grossberg lawsuit against Fox and Tucker is also named as a
defendant in that suit describes a culture of misogyny and
religious discrimination at the network.
Carlson had no comment on the lawsuit.
Fox at the time said it hired independent outside counsel to investigate the concerns raised
by Grossberg.
Fox and News Corp.
The company of the Wall Street Journal's publisher share common ownership.
Carlson.
Now off the air has declined to comment on his future plans.
Some people have speculated that he might take on a career in
politics.
Um Some people have talked about,
you know,
him launching his own media venture of some sort or
joining another network.
Um,
but he hasn't commented on what he's going to do next for Fox
News.
His ouster leaves a prime time hole.
The network is currently relying on a rotation of hosts until it names a permanent anchor for the
A PM slot.
Historically,
when anchors have left Fox,
the network has survived.
There are a number of examples of really prominent people who have left the left the
network and launched their own careers.
Megyn Kelly,
Bill o'reilly Glenn Beck.
Um,
but Fox nonetheless has found talent to replace them.